during the we beat the Chiefs they they
came up to me during the um they came up
to me during the uh bye and beginning of
the bye Monday or Tuesday and they told
me that uh if I didn't change my
contract my injury guaranteed that I'd
be uh you know that I I'd be benched for
the rest of the year and for I don't
know I think we had nine games left or
so I was definitely disappointed about
it and um it was a process throughout
the whole week um for a whole by week
and um you know it was it was uh you
know we just came off beating the Chiefs
played a pry good game against the
Chiefs we just came off of that so I was
excited obviously for us fight for the
playoffs and get on a hot streak and um
you know and then uh you know NFL PA and
NFL got involved or whatever I think but
at some point but I think you know for
me you know I just you know I I came
here to to um to play here um to to to
win I knew it was going to be a process
to to uh you know you know I signed a
seven-year deal to you know for us to go
and play hard and that's my goal every
every time I step in between the white
lines is give everything I have
have